voici le jardin du plessis sagnières un
havre de paix au sein d'un domaine privé
où l'on vient écouter le bruissement du
vent dans les feuilles
la rumeur continue des cascades tout en
se délectant du parfum des fleurs pour
les visiteurs c'est un moment hors du
temps et de ses turpitudes
nous avons tous besoin d'air non vicié
et 2
de sortir du cadre citadins à
redécouvrir la nature et puis trouver de
l'apaisement surtout c'était vraiment
très agréable très calme et il s'appelle
bel vendômoise c'était pour ça que je
voulais la voir
voici l'architecte de ce jardin
l'anglais une passionnée des plantes de
90 printemps qui oeuvrent chaque jour à
en faire un lieu d'exception
un éden où elle veille d'abord sur le
bonheur du visiteur ce qu'ils aiment le
moins c'est de justement comme de m
masques mais on ne leur demande que
quand ils traversent bâtiment et on leur
dit que dès qu'ils sont dans le jardin
ils peuvent l'enlever parce que c'est
vrai que je pense pas que ya des petits
micros partout qui nous visent cette
liberté préservés grâce à une
distanciation aisée dans un parc de 11
hectares est sans doute la clé du succès
actuel jamais le jardin du plessis
sagnières n'avait connu une telle
fréquentation et surtout conquis un
public si divers les gens sont venus ils
ont payé leur droit d'entrée et ils ont
découvert quelque chose qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas les parcs et jardins
et notre jardin et honnêtement on a une
fréquentation qui est supérieure à celle
de l'an dernier qui était une bonne
année un ce est donc et avec des gens
qui je crois ne serait pas venu à nous
dans des conditions qu'on appelle
maintenant normale tendance
conjoncturelle ou changement pérenne
seul le bilan de l'année 2021 si elle
échappe à la pandémie pourra permettre
de conclure